hola a todos en los siguientes vídeos
voy a estar hablando acerca de
diferentes tipos de ejercicios de
optimización algo llamado un ejercicio
de optimización con restricciones así
que imagina que tenemos el siguiente
ejercicio
nos piden maximizar un tipo de función
multi variable así que déjenme notarlo
queremos maximizar una función que les
voy a poner el siguiente nombre voy a
decir que quiero maximizar efe de x
james es una función multi variable y
voy a decir que esta función es igual a
x cuadrada por jim ok entonces lo que
quiero hacer es maximizar esta función
pero le voy a poner una restricción la
restricción es esta quiero encontrar el
máximo de esta función en el conjunto y
voy a pensar en el circulo unitario en
el conjunto x cuadrada
y cuadrada igual a 1 observa esto de
aquí es el círculo unitario déjame
notarlo este de aquí es el círculo
unitario
así que una manera en la que podrían
pensar un ejercicio como éste ya saben
estás optimizando una cierta función de
dos variables es pensar en la gráfica de
esa función como lo que tengo aquí a la
izquierda
esta es la gráfica de f de xy
igual a x cuadrada por james y ahora
esta restricción que tengo aquí
básicamente es un subconjunto del plano
así que si vemos por encima de la
gráfica y vemos el plano x en este
círculo de rojo representa todos los
puntos x m
tales que x cuadrada más cuadrada es
igual a 1 y lo que en realidad dibuje
aquí no es un círculo en el plano x
james pero lo he proyectado en la
gráfica así que esto básicamente les
está mostrando los valores que contiene
esta restricción y además como se ve
cuando se grafican así que la manera en
la que pueden pensar un ejercicio común
este que tengo aquí es observando este
círculo este tipo de círculo proyectado
en la gráfica y buscar los puntos más
altos y aquí podrás notar una especie de
pico en este círculo ondulado y por acá
hay otro y luego también puedes buscar
los puntos más bajos que estarían ya
saben alrededor de este punto de kim y
alrededor de aquí ahora esta forma de
ver el problema de una manera gráfica es
adecuada pero en realidad hay una mejor
manera de visualizarlo es decir usar los
términos adecuados para encontrar la
solución real y la mejor manera de
verdúm es trabajando sólo en el plano xy
en lugar de tratar de graficar cosas y
solo limitar nuestra perspectiva al
espacio de entrada así que lo que tengo
aquí son las curvas de nivel para amd fx
igual a x cuadrada james y si no están
familiarizados con la idea de las curvas
de nivel o de mapas de curvas de nivel
tengo un vídeo sobre este tema al cual
pueden regresar y echarle un vistazo ya
que este concepto va a ser fundamental
para los siguientes vídeos que
trabajemos pero básicamente en cada una
de estas
representa cierto valor constante de f
entonces por ejemplo uno de ellos podría
representar todos los valores de x de
yemen donde el fbi james f de x james
esto fuera no sea igual a 2 se me ocurre
bien así que si ven todos los valores de
x y donde fx es igual a 2 encontrarás
una de estas curvas y cada curva
representa un posible valor diferente
para tu constante así que lo que voy a
hacer por aquí es sólo acercarme a una
curva de nivel en particular y lo que
voy a querer hacer es cambiar cuánto
vale la constante a la cual está
igualada
efe de xm y observen como la curva de
nivel cambian como resultado de esto así
que si borro esto y pensemos en que voy
a ver a efe de xy
igual a la constante 0.1 entonces como
se va a ver esta efe de que james es
igual a 0.1 entonces todos los valores
en estas dos curvas de nivel
les dicen que valores de x de james
satisfacen 0.1 pero por otro lado
también podría desplazar de estas curvas
de nivel y voy a fijar las donde la
constante en realidad sea igual a 1 es
más vamos a escribirlo por separado voy
a ponerlo por separado y ahora me voy a
fijar en qué es lo que pasa con efe de x
james y ahora lo voy a igualar a otra
constante a la constante uno bueno
observa que por aquí hay algunos valores
como 0.1 donde esta curva de nivel
interese acá al círculo intersectan con
nuestra restricción y vamos a pensar en
lo que eso significa bueno eso quiere
decir que si hay un punto
xy un punto x que cumpla que ft que sea
igual a 0.1 y que además cumpla que x
cuadrado más que cuadrada esto sea igual
a 1 porque cumple estas dos cumplen
nuestra función y cumple
nuestra restricción entonces esto
básicamente nos va a dar un par de
números
xm tales que esto de aquí sea verdadero
y de hecho podemos ver que hay cuatro
pares diferentes de números donde esto
es verdadero donde intersectan justo
aquí y aquí y las otras dos
simétricamente de este lado pero por el
otro lado si vemos a este como otro
escenario donde desplazamos la línea
arriba de fx igual a 1 ésta nunca se
intersecta con la restricción es decir
eso significa que si tomas un par de
números
esta vez x gent x gent que satisfagan
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí en esta
ocasión estamos fuera de la restricción
entonces déjame escribirlo estamos fuera
fuera de x cuadrada más 10 cuadrada
esto igual
es decir a medida de que tratamos de
optimizar esta función sujeta a esta
restricción es que no podemos ir tan
arriba como 10.1 sería alcanzable y de
hecho si podemos regresar y observar en
0.1 que si subimos ese valor a 0.2
entonces también es posible ya que se
intersecta con el círculo observa y de
hecho pueden jugar con eso e incrementar
de un poco más y si bojan a 0.3 es más
déjenme escribirlo en lugar de 0.2 ahora
pongo a 0.3 a 0.3 entonces también es
posible y básicamente lo que estamos
tratando de hacer es encontrar el valor
máximo que podamos poner en fx y el
valor máximo de modo que si observamos
la línea que representa
fx james igual a ese valor todavía enter
cerca con el círculo y la clave aquí en
la observación clave es que ese valor
máximo ocurre cuando estas líneas y el
círculo son tangentes en el vídeo
siguiente empezar a entrar
de cómo podemos usar esa observación es
decir esta noción de tangencia para
resolver el ejercicio dicho otra manera
para encontrar el valor real de x de que
optimicen esta función efe
igual a x cuadrada james sujeta a esta
restricción pero en el intermedio entre
éste y el próximo vídeo quiero que
reflexione sobre esto y piensas un poco
acerca de cómo podrías usar la tangencia
entre estas dos curvas es decir que
significa tangencia y cómo pueden sacar
provecho de otras ciertas nociones que
hemos aprendido del cálculo
multivariable como pista piensa en el
gradiente que en realidad resuelve
ejercicios como este así que con esto
acabo en este vídeo y los veo en el
siguiente